you make fifty thousand dollars a year
and you work nine to five and you are
smiling every day You've Won life I
believe there are millions of people who
should be working their face off every
minute because they love it they're good
at it and it brings them Joy I think
there are hundreds of millions of people
that need to stop working so much
because they don't love it they're only
doing it to buy [__] to impress people
they don't even like
still trade attention and build
businesses
yeah
we have to build the apparel business
and then build demand for the art so I
would go content Community Commerce
collectible content which you've done
because content for everyone is
achievable you don't want to make
content and you can't make a lot of it
and you don't want to learn how to do
all of it well then I got nothing for
you because it's [__] free let's talk
about Community here's where you got to
start a Discord here's where you got to
start a text Community here's where you
got to start weekly Google Hangout where
people come in you have a built
Community yet yeah the garyvee story as
a content creator is lost people think
of it as content it was Community even
above content next we go into Commerce
now when you have 700 of that 150 000
now 100 of them are going to buy a 100
hoodie now you're starting and then
after that gets built then I would go to
collect okay
[Music]
okay
econ's kicking off tomorrow kind of tell
me what this is all about the ambition
of the conference itself is to be kind
of the coolest business conference in
the world popular culture meets
contemporary business and so a lot of
Fortune 500 marketers a lot of
entrepreneurs that have built their
businesses mixing that all together over
a you know three day period and for the
people that are actually going to the
conference two things one I want them to
leave with a new friend hence be friends
I think the relationships that are made
in conferences like this are profound
like-minded individuals meeting each
other from around the world and then I
you know I want them to leave with two
or three nuggets of information
rethinking the way they're thinking
about AI or an nft or how to run their
business or a social media strategy and
then there's a whole lot of positive
motivation in the building and so those
things stand out
thrills don't count for living
[Music]
when's my next call now I know this is
something that you've talked about in
the past working hard in your 20s and
not going on vacation and not doing all
that stuff do you still have that you
know working harder mentality the thing
that's always lost when I talk is the
nuances when people talk about that era
of conversation you have to understand
that was 2008-9 and we were going
through a massive recession when I talk
about what I did in my 20s I talk about
that from a framework of self-awareness
of what worked for me for example I
don't believe the way I did it is common
I don't think that most people at 22
years old are wildly obsessed with
building their family's business for
their parents they sacrificed everything
for me I was born in the Soviet Union we
came here we had nothing my dad worked
every minute to establish our family
here my mom loved me better than any mom
loved any person on Earth and I am going
to spend Bend this energy I have inside
of me in my 20s to build as big of a
business as possible for them so that
they can enjoy their lives that they
were unable to because of what I was
going to impact I had a very clear
Mission and enjoyed building an enormous
business for my parents and changing the
history of my parents and impacting my
brother and sister along the way that's
not most people's framework to answer
your question my going hard had a seed
of love not a seed of insecurity to
prove to everybody I needed money to do
something and I loved every second of it
I have to do a better job and people
have to pay a little closer attention to
the words because for example the first
book I wrote which talked about go and
crush it within the book it says if you
make fifty thousand dollars a year and
you work nine to five and you are
smiling every day You've Won life but
people don't like to pick on that part
they like to talk about the extremes of
the conversation I believe there are
millions of people who should be working
their face off every minute because they
love it they're good at it and it brings
them Joy I think there are hundreds of
millions of people that need to stop
working so much because they don't love
it they're only doing it to buy [__] to
impress people they don't even like
that's the conversations I think we need
to have not what's work-life balance
work-life balance is individual to every
person on Earth are you going to tell
someone who wants to do something for
their family to work a little less for
their mental health you don't know their
mental health the best mental health I
ever had was when I was building
something for my parents so that's me
it's really cool
[Music]
gotta be for sure
[Applause]
[Music]
somebody took you were in the background
of one of my photos
and somebody said your dad looks like
he's about to drop the hardest album
he's ever drives
other side and finally made
[Music]
selling products art yeah and it's a
skill there's two ways to think about it
one continuing to lean in two taking the
jump just to see if you can and being
okay with failure yeah three bringing in
a partner on the selling stuff that
actually knows how to do it yeah and
it's sharing the revenue it's not only a
long game it's a talent game are you
capable I think I have pretty like good
grounding skills so then I would say
even that answer you always have to do
it because if you don't you'll always
regret not trying you gotta try laughing
in the face cause I'm still here I got
the drive you fellas better still clear
birthed all of this from an idea I just
cut a buzz we ain't heard from you in
light years I'm just pointing with you
better swing for the fast never play
fair wonder where all the real went out
of style I always get more than 100
[Music]
yeah you saved my life I know you hear
this a lot I thought I was done and said
these words you said 50th half time I
was 48 I just went [__] he's right and I
went from an abusive relationship to a
good place that left my job new job I
love it my kids are safe we're all safe
and it's awesome just those words words
like one thing yeah literally saved my
life in all four of my children's lives
with that word it's such a pleasure to
see you hey Gary
such a pleasure hey thank you so much
happy to do it brother watching your
content and and seeing the way that my
life has improved instantly you know
helping my connection with my mom you
know we haven't had the best of the past
sure those are challenging circumstances
a lot of circumstances but the beauty is
you have so much more time in front of
you after watching about maybe three
four months of your content I live to
Colorado and just started Living for
myself and I've been feeling so good
about it I'm glad thank you so much
I've come to the stadium for three
football games and left happy twice but
only didn't win the most important one
hey everybody
take a sale take a self better run a
little son take a hit make it here
about to give a keynote at vcon
this weekend and I've decided to
incorporate all of you so if you can do
we want them to put the video in in
community reply with the videos right
yeah so if you want to reply with a
question I want my theme to be around
fear and eliminating fear and what's
holding you back so I want to give a
keynote about fear and I'd like you to
be a part of my keynote I'm actually
going to put you up on the big jumbo
screens throughout asking the question
I'm going to answer it to the
of my
um
keynote by asking a video question just
reply here with your video questions the
team's gonna go through them and we're
gonna pick a dozen or so and we're gonna
answer them and I might pick some others
and the team and I may just put that
into our social media so reply with the
question around the theme of fear thank
you see ya
[Music]
how do you react Gary to the Montana
news people are asking me all the time
what happens if Tick Tock gets banned
I'm like I don't even care if all of
social media gets banned I just care
about where attention is when I look at
some of the data that you just throw out
four hours on Tick Tock well I lived
seven hours a day on television I
consumed four hours of CNBC in the
background all the time so the human
behavior of media consumption always
evolves so whether Tick Tock gets banned
whether all of social gets banned the
attention is going to go somewhere else
and whether that's Spotify or I heart
radio or CNBC or walking outside the
reality is I'm agnostic to the
distribution I'm just focused on being
able to storytell within it
thank you that was awesome
see you tomorrow
courage so I can quit my job last year I
was able to live my dream man I listened
to your podcast all the time and you
gave me courage to get out there I'm
proud of you bro let this be very
[__] clear love is unfucking defeated
put your hands in the air drinks in your
cup if you don't give a [__]